[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people we have a
brilliant guest today in our socially
distant studio as you're about to see
she's the director of the equinox
project and i follow him and welcome
back to trigonometry thank you for
having me again
yeah it's good to have you back it's
been nearly a year i introduced you as a
director of the equinox project which
didn't exist the last time we
interviewed you
uh what has been going on with you in
the last year
yeah i know it's been a really really
crazy year obviously a lot of people
first really heard of me significantly
when i kind of intervened and to an
extent in the kind of identity politics
debate that was going on
um kind of early last year and then
august i kind of launched the
organization called the the ecuano
project slightly in response to the kind
of black lives matter protest but kind
of a broader um desire to kind of
hopefully move the conversation forward
in regards to kind of identity politics
and things like that
so we had our first event which was
attended and that guest speakers like
trevor phillips and catherine burble
sing and aisha
akambi has also been on this show and it
was really fantastic
and since then we've been kind of going
into schools and
and speaking to people about how we can
respond to many of these really
important issues about kind of
colonialism and history and race and
identity
but from a more kind of humanist
universalist perspective that's not kind
of driven
ideologically um solely from a kind of
narrow lens of identity politics and
kind of
race consciousness and that deeply kind
of politicized narrative of race so
that's really where where it's been at
and hopefully lots of new
exciting projects on freedom of speech
and and a lot of these important
conversations
you definitely moved the conversation
forward when we had you aisha and zubin
in in short succession uh we then got
kicked out of our last studio so
things are moving in the right direction
[Laughter]
no i think i think it has been really
positive i think you know in the
beginning of the conversation i think a
lot of people
were thinking where is it going to go
but what we've really seen is so many
people from a genuine diversity of
backgrounds ethnic minorities in
particular that are saying that
a lot of this conversation doesn't
represent them and actually just like
any group of people regardless of your
background there's real
ideological and political diversity and
that that fundamentally needs to be
heard if we are to kind of really delve
into
these these questions so i think it's
not been as bad hopefully
a year later it's moved forward so you
think it's actually calmed down a bit
now or do do you not think that we're
gonna we're gonna see another eruption
i think it's a really difficult one i
mean i mean two years ago i
i think very few people would have
predicted whether that was kind of
covered
or even black lives matter and i guess
the nature of kind of society is
is the kind of spontaneity that emerges
with it but i think what has happened
now which
seems very different to last year is
that there seems to have emerged
many different organizations now in
response to a lot of these movements so
if something
does happen there's a kind of
infrastructure a social solidarity in
place to be able to respond to it
and kind of um and bring forth the kind
of voices that have a different
perspective on these issues so i think
that in terms of
the kind of uh the kind of knowledge
about the kind of complexity of the
issue it's moved forward
but there are still so many um
challenges i think that
for example you know one of the things
that have now arisen in regards to this
conversation very recently
has been the kind of conversation around
kind of big tech censorship
so we still have um many significant
challenges in order to kind of open the
conversation
around many of these complex issues so
there's still much more to be done i
think
and the obvious question i suppose would
be given that
your project deals with schools we're
seeing in america now particularly and
as we know whenever they get something
we get it
we used to be five years later now we
get it two weeks later
is critical race theory can you explain
to people
what that is yeah so i i think i'm a lot
of people over the last
year have attempted to to make sense of
this kind of theory that has often come
to shape
the conversation about race i mean helen
pluck pros and james lindsay are very
um famous for kind of problematizing
that the nature of that theory
and it is very complicated but i think
if it's actually what's interesting
about it is actually quite logically
consistent if you accept some of the
premises of it
so obviously it it kind of posits that
racism is kind of ever present embedded
in um
every element of society and so as helen
pluckrose mentions it's not
kind of did racism happen in a given uh
interaction
is how did racism manifest itself and so
you know people are
split up into uh the oppressor versus
oppressed
and thank you for looking at me
on you yes the moment that she said how
did racism manifest
itself and she just went i rated him
straight
tonight he's used to it yeah it's all
right
it's the voice i know it's the voice
you've got a delicious shade of gammon
there as well
you know we're just messy you know what
it's such a pleasure to have a human
being back
in like face to face that would we just
enjoy messing around but
you're making an important point which
is this is a system
that presumed that racism happens
whenever people of different races
coexist in the same space
exactly and you know and your the
legitimacy of your voice depends on your
positionality where you stand in
relation to dynamics of
power and privilege and each individual
is made up of these kind of
competing intersections of different uh
interlocking systems of oppression
whether that's your race your gender
your sexuality
one of the things i find so um
challenging about this this theory and
it is a theory it's not fact
um is you never become a full human
being
you know and what i mean by that is
human beings are never seen in their
totality
they're always kind of competing
identity categories
and so this makes it very difficult to
have a meaningful conversation
it's not human being to human being it's
not this idea that we all have empathy
and that means that
we can at least if not if we've not
experienced direct discrimination we can
at least imagine what it might feel like
and that's
our human empathy that the thread that
unites us all regardless of our identity
category
and so you could never fully transcend
that according to this theory
we're always just in this constant loop
of kind of
competing power dynamics and i don't
think that's a context
for um human beings to fully exercise
their agency and
and transcend the kind of identity
categories and political abstractions
assigned upon them
and so you know again the echino project
hopes to really
re-articulate that universalist
perspective of martin luther king
frederick douglass
booker t washington and and a long
tradition that goes a long way
and do you think we're at risk of this
being introduced into schools
because i know there's been that you
know there's a there's been the issue
with eaton
and you know and firing that particular
teacher but do you think
we're at risk now this being introduced
into state schools up and down the
country
i think it's already become incredibly
institutionalized i think um for example
we see it in the corporate world with
the whole kind of diversity and
inclusion
and then and this kind of seeing people
as uh
you know constantly a threat to one
another that needs to be micromanaged
um and all of these kind of diversity
trainings there's an entire industry now
and i think understandably you know most
people i think we've come a long way as
society find racism
to be abhorrent and if there's a kind of
group of people consistently saying that
it's embedded in society and it
and it's you know so pervasive then
understandably you know
people feel that they want to do
something about it and so the challenges
now as i kind of alluded to earlier is
ensuring that
and increasing the kind of platforms for
people that have that different
perspective okay by all means put
forward the critical race perspective i
don't believe it should be
censored or removed but as long as we
understand that it is one lens for
looking at things and there are multiple
and i think that's i think what um for
example the kind of kemmie badernotch um
statement where she talked about
kind of teaching it as one um objective
truth is really the problem as long as
you're
demonstrating along a wide range of
views can we then i think get closer to
the truth
you have to ask a question as well like
i'm a former teacher everyone can now
drink
but when we kids are struggling with
their literacy with their numeracy
is this really the thing that we should
be using lesson time for shouldn't we
teach me
about geography history etc etc well i
absolutely i think um i mean one of the
subjects i'm really interested in
is the kind of subject of kind of
freedom of speech which is a kind of
fundamental
basis of democracy and one of another
issue that's been
really strong amongst younger
generations is the kind of suspicion
towards freedom of speech or
any time we think about freedom of
speech is often consistently framed in
relation to spreading hate or
or attacks against minorities and the
kind of real kind of virtue and meaning
of that
has um become distorted in the
conversation and that's something that i
think is fundamental to
young people's cultivation of their own
sense of individuality and agency
and so a fixating over race on a
generation that may well be
the most uh open-minded towards
different um
racial groups um than previous
generations perhaps in history
i think is is um is a really distracting
thing i think there's way way way more
issues i mean particularly in the
pandemic
that young people are facing right now i
mean having their kind of
educational life decimated is one
example and i don't think that
fixating on racism amongst young people
is a very productive thing to focus on
do you think a big part of this is
technology because one of the things i
have been
aware of recently is that the power of
technology is so great and
as we record this this whole gamestop
thing is happening right
where essentially a bunch of ordinary
people have worked out that if you use
technology to band together
you can be really powerful and of course
the powers that be want to shut that
down do you think
a big part of this whole attempt to
restrict what people say is
that modern technology is so powerful
that you know one person saying
something can turn into a thousand
people saying something and before you
know it half the country believes
something that isn't true
let's say right do you think that's a
lot of a lot of the reasons that there's
this fear about freedom of expression
i think that's a really good question
and i i think there's a lot of truth in
it i think
um i think we kind of forget that we
haven't had social media
for a very long time and actually
something so revolutionary like the
ability to
instantaneously communicate with the
entire world and kind of spread that
message to the world has
transformational um effects and i think
we are still navigating that territory
and kind of figuring out
um what that means and i do think it
absolutely does have very real
consequences so
you know as you just alluded to you can
say something that may be
false um particularly in a situation of
crisis that we're dealing with and i
think people
do have legitimate concerns about what
the consequences of that might lead to
but i guess the question is how do we
really respond to that
and i think part of our kind of drive to
restrict and to stifle is a kind of lack
of confidence
in our institutions in our civic society
um to be vibrant enough and
intellectually
rigorous enough and dynamic enough to be
able to actually
challenge those things so our in our
instinctive response is to just center
it
but obviously as we've seen that doesn't
work i think it you know it's one of the
oldest
you know statements tricks in the book
that if you do censor something
it doesn't stop people from believing it
you know you can kind of put your head
in the sand you can ignore it
but people still hold those views and i
think that when people
um are not allowed the space to be able
to express them to um
you know allow their idea to really be
refined against the views of other
people
then i think you know as as many people
as have said it it often moves
um underground and i think that's a much
more kind of dangerous situation and i
think that
a much more confident um civic life will
actually want those views to be
be out there and for us to be able to
respond to that and you know i think
it's really hard at the moment
because again with the kind of lockdown
conditions
we don't really have a public square in
the same sense
so you know what that means is that the
way we can experience people in a much
more multi-dimensional way
such as you know going to the pub or
going to a kind of event with lots of
people and debating
isn't there so the only domain really we
have now to really experience even
a fraction of another human being is
through these kinds of uh
these channels these social media
channels so by removing people you're
essentially unpersoning them
you're saying there's no domain in the
public square in the digital public
square that exists
and for for you to actually express
yourself and i think that that can um
arise much more kind of dangerous
consequences so what did you make
of the consequences of the attack on the
capital or the
whatever whatever happened right the
consequences of that
where you start with the president of
the united states being banned from
the platform that he uses to talk to
people uh
then parlor uh get gets its service
taken down
uh then as i mentioned gamestop you get
these people trading
and that gets called hate speech the the
forums get shut down and whatever
it seems like and my view isn't that
you've got these nefarious people like
sitting there in a smoke-filled room
whatever it just seems like
these kids really have got these massive
corporations through which we all
communicate
in their hands and they suddenly go oh
my god like i have so much power
and that's probably quite scary to them
and they don't know what to do and
they've got
you know sam harris came out and thanked
jack dorsey for banning donald trump
so you're going well if sam harris is
telling you to ban stuff
like how do you hold that line exactly i
think it's incredibly difficult
i think that these are really really um
complex questions and i think that
we're in a climate right now where we
have kind of narrative warfare
so if a kind of event happens and i
think many people like douglas murray
have spoken about this if a kind of
event happens
there's um instead of relying on again
traditional
media to kind of tell us the close to
the impartial truth of the events
we have all of these narratives that
emerge and these narratives are often
purely kind of ideological in in reading
and so it just becomes a kind of
battleground between
who's going to whose narrative is going
to really dominate and so
a lot of these uh kind of big tech
companies essentially have to end up
choosing you know which narrative aligns
most to many of their values and a lot
of the time they are this kind of
corporate
liberal values and many of those people
are saying actually
you know sensor disinformation sensor
hate speech if you don't do this then
you're part of the problem
and i think i think they genuinely are
um in a in a kind of difficult situation
but i do think you know i absolutely do
believe that they um kind of bear a lot
of responsibility for
um i i do think that there are incentive
structures you know within social media
companies
that kind of um exaggerate um the kinds
of things that you're
exposed to in these kinds of echo
chambers and as i said when we are in a
situation where the kind of digital
public square is these social media
companies
then i think it makes that situation
much more difficult if you are not
being exposed to lots of different
viewpoints and so i think they are in a
difficult situation and i'm not sure
that
i don't know if the answer is going to
be in these social media platforms
because
ultimately you know for example with
twitter it is just kind of one
one tweet that you send that's not
that's not a full experience of a kind
of human being that's not a full
way to kind of understand one another i
think it's it's unlikely that
um that the social media companies are
really now going to be the domain
um the current ones at least twitter
where we can really um
have an open climate for for different
ideas i think we i think we need new
things now
i think that we need to start creating
new spaces new open spaces
um where no topics are off limits where
are kind of based off of shared values
not necessarily kind of
stale terms of service and where we can
genuinely
have conversations with with people from
from different
ideological backgrounds in a much more
fuller and richer way not not just just
in the form of a kind of message
or a tweet and i think that's where um i
think that the space is really open now
for for much more spaces um like that in
the digital arena do we need 3d reality
yeah we do i think that's what you need
yeah exactly
have you ever been abroad and felt out
of place because you didn't speak the
language
no because i voted brexit brexit means
brexit
i know that sometimes you're abroad you
don't speak the local language it's very
awkward like france is talking to a
woman
so you have to shout do you want to
learn another language
i don't for obvious reasons but if you
do
babel is quite simply one of the finest
language learning apps in the business
babel offers a clear and easy to use
interface they have daily 10 to 15
minute lessons
that have been proven effective across
many studies
showing that you can learn up to 14
languages that they offer
so it doesn't matter if you struggle
with language maybe you find it
difficult to pick up or maybe you're
just
english right now babel is offering our
fans
six months free on a six-month
subscription with babel
using our special code which is of
course trigger
that's babble b a b b
e l dot co dot uk
play and use the promo code trigger look
at that spelling he learned english on
babel
i did but seriously go to babble.com
uk forward slash play use our code
trigger and enjoy babel
i mean it's a great point that you made
but isn't part of the problem now with
lockdown
in that these companies have become ever
more draconian if you look at someone
like youtube
they've basically said that if you put
any form of content
criticizing lockdown or wh o guidelines
on policies
you're going to get struck off i i think
they're playing i agree with you i think
it's become
absolutely worse i think we're in a
really really dangerous kind of perilous
situation where
there's almost there's very few spaces
now where where if it's not being
overtly censored
there's a kind of pernicious culture of
kind of self-censorship
and where people don't feel comfortable
speaking because of fear of the
consequences and that's
you know what what has been spoken about
in the past cancer culture where
this is not a this is not an imaginary
threat that a lot of people would like
to believe
it's a real threat for people like for
example nick buckley you know who
thankfully and was able to get
his charity back that if you do veer
away from the orthodoxy
then there is a a real and pernicious
threat that you could lose your
livelihood and i think that
if we're in a situation now where big
tech companies that are unaccountable
um unelectable and incredibly opaque in
terms of their policies have the power
to remove people's livelihood
then that's a fundamental free speech
issue and i think that we are in a very
dangerous situation
absolutely and do you think we could
possibly go along the poland route which
has
effectively said that they're going to
find these social media companies
if they take down content which doesn't
contravene polish law
i think that that is the possibility you
know i i did look into that and i think
that's a very i think that
we'll have to see how that actually
transpires i think that
again the challenge is is that and i do
think there's definitely a role for the
state
and a role for a kind of top-down
response but i think that um
the kind of state intervening in a lot
of these issues um
seems quite uh problematic and
complicated for for various reasons
because
freedom of speech not just has to be
protected from a kind of legalistic
perspective which is absolutely
important but it also has to be believed
in people's hearts and i think that
that's really
um one of the other challenges that i
think is
also contributing to this current
climate where actually
um the kind of real embodiment of free
speech the kind of spirit of
confronting ideas and challenging them
in many spaces
and still hasn't been fully um
actualized and so as much as there could
be legal protections if it's not fully
um
believed in then we'll still have that
as john stuart mill describes the kind
of the tyranny of prevailing opinion
no that's a really good point because i
guess the only way to to
to change this in the long term is to
change the culture which is what you're
saying and i imagine what you're trying
to do
with with the crown of project yeah to
get in there at the at a younger
point and try and explain to to the kids
uh
you know what what that's all about but
in the meantime
i mean i don't have a i used to have
quite a libertarian
mindset when it came to these big tech
things but
i think we've seen now you know you talk
about these new spaces
parlor tried to create one didn't end so
well
right do you see what i'm saying so i i
i don't see how
that gets fixed without government
intervening and whatever else it might
be
well so this is um you know another
thing that has been uh
something that i've been really working
on for for the past year now
and i think that um i i don't think i do
think there's definitely a role for
government but i do think there's got to
be
a collaborative kind of civil society
response i think for example the stuff
that trigonometry are doing are amazing
in terms of facilitating these
conversations
but i think civil society also has to
play
a really significant role in kind of
pushing back against this to kind of
cultivate this um
this bottom-up response and so there is
a project as well
um that with the free speech union and
the battle of ideas charity that
myself and a lot of other young people
have actually been working on for nearly
a year now
and it's launching um called free speech
champions
and i'm really really excited about this
project because it's a it's a kind of
nationwide initiative in order to kind
of encourage
free speech and very much from the
bottom up focus on kind of younger
people
and i think that there are real kind of
practical material ways that we can do
this so for example
one of the things that we're we're doing
is cultivating a group of
called free speech champions the
champions themselves are these young
people between the kind of ages of 18
to 30 that really believe in free speech
from a kind of diverse range of
perspectives that go
out um into kind of schools universities
and these places to kind of spread the
message about why it's important
and hopefully bringing more young people
together but not just that
providing the information the resources
uh the the kind of everything that's
needed to actually really campaign for
it so for example one of the things that
we've done on the website
is to have a guide to how to set up a
free speech society
how to campaign for free speech on
campus because i think that when we
think about free speech
it's such a big topic but i do think
there's lots of little things that
people can do collectively
to really actually start to change the
culture and i think it is
it is a legal question and i think there
was a a thing in the express recently of
prissy patel
perhaps wanting to do something with the
hate speech laws but there has to be
something and very much from the bottom
up
and creating those spaces whether online
or in in the actual rural public square
where people can't there are no
forbidden topics so people can really
express themselves
because i think that's the kind of
fundamental prerequisite for
for real human agency for really
exploring the kind of depth and scope of
our humanity because i think without it
um you know social and human progress
you know it is incredibly diminished
so there's possibilities out there and i
think um a collaborative endeavor
um with people across the political
spectrum you know in the form of kind of
free speech champions
to really push back against this i think
could really be the start of something
quite significant
do you think i can't believe i'm
actually saying this but i'm going to
say this
do you not think yeah yeah it sounds
again my voice but do you not think
that the the label free speech has
actually been tarnished to the point
that immediately
when people hear it they go oh it's just
some you know right wing bloke you know
with a swastika who just wants to drop m
bombs
yes i it is really unfortunate and i
think you know one of the things about
the kind of culture wars that has been
really frustrating is that
a lot of people think you know people in
the culture wars want to
weaponize free speech but you know in my
view i think free speech has been more
victim
of the of the culture wars than a weapon
of it
and so i i think i think it has to be
reclaimed you know i i don't think that
we should be able to they should be able
to seed linguistic territory
where we're not able to use the the
language
that is widely understood to express
concepts that are also widely understood
and i think when we see that linguistic
territory again then we're in a
much more difficult position to push
back against it when we don't actually
have the words to really describe it
and so free speech you know is not a
dirty word it is a
is a fundamental bedrock or of a kind of
free and open democratic society and we
should be really confident
in articulating that this is such an
obvious point but the fact that you have
to explain it is
is kind of mind-blowing in a way no it
absolutely is and so you're going into
school you've been working with these
kids so
how do they perceive free speech do they
see it as something that should be
celebrated or a tool of white oppression
or whatever it is
yeah so that's the free speech champions
and project it launches on the first of
february but even before that um you
know i i was going into schools and
speaking about free speech
and what's been really interesting and i
think there was also some research that
was done about it
which was that um you know when you
actually articulate the arguments
about free speech then people are much
more um compelled by them just kind of
saying
you know believe in free speech you know
it's really important does is not that
convincing because i don't think the
kind of substance of the meaning has
really been
conceptualized and really grasped but
when you really um you know
explain the fact that for example social
movements the world over
um free speech has been essential for
them to actually challenge the
institutions
and that we're kind of subjugating them
by articulating their suffering
or or it's necessary for the kind of the
challenging of orthodoxies and rigidity
um and so is there's something
incredibly radical about it
or you know gregory kiranov talks about
free speech as the eternally radical
idea
and young people that are often you know
wanting to to
both in some senses be conformist but
also be perceived as the kind of
new radicals i think that actually when
free speech is articulated in a way that
um
it it's not you know something you know
dull or boring or inevitable
it's actually something that we have to
fight for every single day because
in many senses it's against all odds and
so i think
going back perhaps to those kind of core
foundational
and principles and rediscovering i think
and
a lot of these kind of heroic stories um
the kind of traditions of the past and
thinking about
what it was about the past that needs to
be interrogated but really
we articulated for the present day and
and positioning ourselves in that
historical trajectory
and i think is really compelling to a
lot of young people
and so i think i think there's a lot of
scope for it do you think it's also
quite fertile ground because you know
you have the people in their 20s who are
uber work very liberal
don't want to upset don't want to be
offensive and do you think you're going
to get a reaction from the generation
below who are like
[ __ ] that i'm going to say what i want
almost as a rebellion
oh abs i think that i really hope so
because i think now the
the um the climate has become so
restrictive there's so many
taboos there's so many you can't say
that you shouldn't say that
you can't offend these people i think
that's exhausting i think it's really
exhausting to be
um i mean you know i'm soon not going to
be a young person in a couple years but
i mean
the young people that have completely um
grown up on social media
where you know from a very young age you
know they're comparing themselves to
other people
you know there's all of these new labels
and terms i think that there's
i think hopefully a new generation will
begin to reject that rigidity
as this kind of orthodoxy it is very
much um the dominant culture
now and so it's it's not something new
or edgy to be um
you know vulnerable and highly offensive
and paternalistic
it is actually something you know
incredibly conformist and boring
it'll be interesting to see what you
find when you when you roll the project
out across the country because
we do keep hearing this narrative now
the the next generation are really not
work at all
which is interesting to me that sort of
makes logical sense that it would be
that way but
you kind of need to see it happening
don't you yeah i i think it is
you know the territory of the space of
the project right now is very
it's like it's like a baby you know it's
very new and i'm i'm really excited to
see where it's going to go but i really
encourage like
you know young people that are really um
interested and curious and open-minded
and
wanting to explore so to kind of join
the project and find out more about it
because i think that this there's a lot
of scope
and i think that i think it is possible
that that people younger especially
having grown up um
in perhaps you know having come to
adulthood or come to maturity
in in a kind of covert situation that
may well be
the the most uh one of the most
restricted when it comes to liberty that
any of us may have ever experienced
that um you know what are the
possibilities that kind of lie beyond
this moment and how do we navigate that
and i so i think that i think a lot of
young people hopefully would be asking
those questions that
surely this isn't inevitable surely we
don't have to accept the
the premise that um human beings uh must
be
uh under such stringent restrictions
whether that's
you know from an institutional level but
from a kind of cultural and ideas level
um inevitably it's interesting well i
mean the kids obviously are not going to
learn any maths at least they'll learn
about free speech right now weren't they
i'm curious you mentioned institutions
and this is something francis and i have
discussed quite a bit
it seems to me like what we're really
talking about is different facets of the
culture or different fronts perhaps on
it
and the the organizations that you've
been involved with
through the free speech union and now
the free speech champions project
they they seem to me like institutions
that are
uh waging that battle do you think
the answer here inevitably has to be
institutional because
so much of this what you might call woke
stuff
has become institutionalized in the
media in government
almost everywhere now in education of
course
uh that you have to fight fire with fire
or you have to fight institutions with
other institutions
yeah now i think that's a really good
question i think that i think a lot of
people do think that the kind of um the
institutions have become beyond repair
have become corrupted but i i'm not so
sure because i think that ultimately
the institutions um are fluid in so far
as they're made up of people
and so if the people that um encompass
or
animate those institutions um that their
views
shift or their views become more open
then i think hope by definition
the institutions themselves should and i
think you know we've gone through worse
things as a society you know whether
that was you know the cold war or
or even previously that have really kind
of challenged and forced us to question
um who we are um as a society and so i
think i think
i i don't lose faith um in those
institutions because a lot of them have
a very long history whether that is in
the media or various cultural
establishments but i do think there is
space um for new ones
um and or based off of different values
that are much
more confident in articulating them and
i think that's really one of the
elements
um people that are confident in standing
up for these things
and are not afraid and are willing to
withstand unfortunately sometimes
the assault that happens and so i think
i i don't give up on the institutions
that exist
but absolutely new ones that are much
more authoritative in their defense of
what they believe to be true and their
values it is absolutely
needed and the free speech union is one
of those ones that is making a really
positive impact well right that's what i
was going to say what i mean is i'm not
so much for tearing down the bbc or
whatever
you know i'm not obsessed with that
she's not judging by your twitter
no i've held the line i've held the line
on the bbc i think they've gone in the
wrong direction but i still think
they're important
but uh something like the free speech
union it's not an
alternative to the bbc what what the
free speech union does
is it allows people who have spoken
their mind
in the wrong place at the wrong time to
not have their life destroyed
you know count away which helen plucker
has just launched
you know we've just had her on the show
again things like that where you're
creating an avenue for people to be able
to express themselves freely
and be protected from the consequences
of the existence prevailing
orthodoxy you know i i completely agree
and i think that's been one of the
reasons why it's been so hard for a lot
of people who who do disagree with
what's going on but
have not necessarily stood up because of
the lack of solidarity
and i think that you know it's always
going to be throughout history and
presently a minority of individuals
individuals that kind of rise up to the
level of being able to kind of withstand
for example toby is one of them you know
he's
experienced you know so much and he he's
he's a kind of fighter
and but not everyone's like that and not
everyone necessarily should be like that
because there's different ways of
approaching this conversation
and one of the things again with free
speech champions is is um
bringing together other young people
that can provide support and solidarity
and
and encourage and really delve into
these ideas together in a really deep
and
and kind of profound way and so when you
have those spaces as you mentioned like
counterweight
that um you know creates a forms of
bonds and solidarities with people that
are
around a kind of common cause then again
that that gives
people more confidence to do things and
so i think it's a process i think it's
absolutely
um i think you know last year a lot of
people
a lot of us kind of perhaps weren't
necessarily as prepared as we could
for the challenges that have kind of
come about but now a year later there's
much more of a vibrant kind of civic
community um that
are wanting to do something and to stand
up and isn't this partly just as well
a basic fundamental which is not cow
towing to bullies
yeah no i think so i think you know that
um
when people think that um there is no
there's not going to be a
any consequence or there's not going to
be a response then they are
empowered to to kind of bully people and
i do think
i think that the word bully it is a very
um good one
and i think um you know douglas murray i
think in an interview
in trigonometry actually mentioned this
about related to the gender debate which
is um
you know how people are kind of uh often
there's something demoralizing about
people being compelled to lie and and
how um
in some senses that kind of reduces um
our own kind of sense of our own
humanity
as we're not able to fully participate
in kind of shaping
um the conversation and the world and i
think that anyone that
encourages people to to keep quiet to
keep their mouth shut
is a is doing very destructive things
and messing with things i think they
they very much shouldn't
yeah it's a powerful point it is that
when douglas talked about it he was
causing courts in soldier knits and
that's what we talked about
that every time you lie it has an impact
on the whole world yeah and you know
that
you know yeah that's what's so dangerous
about it exactly and you feel it and
then you contribute yeah to creating
a society that is ultimately dishonest
because people are not
speaking what they believe to be true
and what would you say to somebody who's
like look okay this light
is this is dishonest what i'm saying but
it's the kind thing to do
if we do that we don't hurt someone's
feelings we don't distress them
which is the counter argument to this
yeah so i think that
there's two things i'd say i think that
we've moved away from the realm of
politeness you know this isn't this
isn't we're not talking about people
being nice to each other
and polite i think the overwhelming
majority of people in their everyday
interactions are polite i think what
what this
is is a very is a stifling and
pernicious pressure to to not say
anything um
even even if the consequences are even
negative
um and so i think that that is um i'm a
different thing but also
in some sense you know there's a price
for freedom and i think that
even though i do articulate the kind of
positive case for free speech
um you know the phrase you know the
price of freedom is eternal vigilance
because actually
there is something um dangerous about
freedom there is something actually
quite scary i mean why would you want to
hear
um what somebody else thinks because
that might fundamentally challenge
everything that you believe or the
the identity or the narrative about the
world that you've um come to construct
about yourself
there's something incredibly confronting
about that and so
i think there is a price you know
freedom of speech and freedom isn't
always
you know sitting around t hearing having
lovely conversations sometimes you will
be exposed
to the alarming to the to the scary to
the intimidating to the offensive
but that exposes us to the real reality
of our humanity which is
both incredibly evil and incredibly good
and we should
want to rise to confront um that real
reality
and but there is indeed a price for that
and just going back to if i just finish
this
with the free speech champions isn't
that a real challenge you're going to
face because
a lot of these kids they're very modern
coddled they're the most modical
generation
they want to be wrapped up in cotton
wool they don't want anything to
challenge them
isn't that going to be very difficult
for your project i think that um
i i think it could be but i would say
that um
i'm not so sure how many young people
really are like that
i think that there is a kind of minority
that dominate the conversation
about um you know creating cushions
around everything and safe spaces and
trigger warnings and no one should
um be offended but i think i do think a
substantial
um kind of amount of young people are
either indifferent
or or or actually very curious uh and so
are
perhaps wasting for or or would grab at
the opportunity if it was in a way that
was done that they believe perhaps
reflects
and their values to kind of um really
engage with these ideas
so i think um i'm not sure i agree with
them
the the kind of view of young people
that is like that i think a minority are
that often dominate the conversation
but i think given the the right space
and the right circumstances
i think as any generation um young
people could
rise up to the level of actually um
confronting these challenges and really
engaging in these conversations
we have a lot of young people who watch
the the interviews we do and
live streams that's how you know they've
got irresponsible parents but
but i was going to ask you do you think
this technology question has been
bugging me and i'm just thinking out
loud here
do you think maybe people like us are
being a little bit naive because
there is so much information now
on the web right the
you are not no matter how intelligent
how well educated you are you're not
capable of processing all of the
information available
even on one issue whatever issue you
take you cannot physically
read every article in the guardian and
every article in the spectator
and every article in between about that
issue
and so no matter how hard you try to to
be open-minded and to listen to other
points
your natural biases are always going to
draw you into
back into that echo chamber do you think
maybe we're just like you're very
optimistic i am very naturally
optimistic him not so much
right it's worked out great for him for
the last year and a half really has he
calls himself fostadamus now
i've been right i've been proved right
on everything he's enjoyed it uh
and uh i've not been able to say
anything about it but do you think that
people like us who are naturally you
know fundamentally optimistic about
society just massively underestimate
how powerful technology is and what a
powerful impact it has on our brains it
has on our behavior it has on everything
so i think um a couple of things so
that's why i think it's been really
unfortunate
seeing the way in which a lot of the
mainstream media so to speak
has actually moved to be much more
partisan so or
or less sticking to that kind of
impartiality because i do think
i do think um as much as i you know
might critique a lot of the things of
the legacy media i think it absolutely
has a fundamental role to play and i
think it's really important
um to be able to kind of rise above a
lot of the kind of conflicting
narrative warfares that go on and
actually present that
information in a way that is as close to
the truth or as close to the truth as it
reveals itself to them as possible and i
think that if we
do have and if those institutions do
actually
reconnect with their fundamental basis
which is to actually
provide solid reliable information
then i think that that is a really
really strong thing as a society
but i do think i agree with you in terms
of the way um
that the power of big tech i absolutely
do think that
but i think that the response to that as
i alluded to earlier
is um a a robust civil society and we
don't have that we just have
one element now where everything is
digitized in the sense that um you know
with the with the kind of conditions at
the moment where everything we get
is through the internet everything all
of our communication is through the
internet
all of the even school university
everything is there
and i think that we we need to have a
counter to that which is real
which is physical which is dynamic which
is interactive which is away from any of
those conversations
and so i think that when this is
balanced the kind of civic life
then that kind of works in a kind of
good dynamic motion with technology but
when it's just only technology
which ultimately is controlled by
private corporations
then there's there's no accountable
power so i think that the the building
of civil society and the public square
again
um will be a counterweight to that
francis did you know that investing is
one of the best ways to preserve your
wealth over the long term
what's well something you will never
find out as long as i have control of
the trigonometry account
however if you do have wealth high
commission and clunky products
from traditional stock brokers make it
very difficult for people like me
to start investing good for everyone
else though
free trading has come up with an
award-winning app that is currently
being used by over 250
000 people it's fca approved and fscs
protected it's brilliant it allows you
to trade commission free
free trade has won best online trading
platform at the british bank awards
two years in a row 2019 and 2020.
they offer no speculative products no
spread betting no day trading
it's all about preserving and growing
your wealth over long term
no hidden fees transparent pricing
structure very simple to use
you can sign up for a general investment
account or a stocks and shares isa
or sign up to free trade plus for more
advanced order types and a bigger stock
universe
they've also got other new products
coming soon you can get a universe
go to free trade dot io trigger register
and fund your account and you'll get a
randomly allocated free share
worth between three and two hundred
pounds could be in a great company like
right move apple even greg's great
when you invest your capital is at risk
the value of your investments
can go up as well as down and you may
receive back
less than you originally invested you
knew that bit off by heart
i was going to ask you something else um
your job mate yeah it is good point i'm
going to do my job right now
uh you you were in america covering the
election yes somewhat
uh what do you think will be the impact
of a biden presidency
uh on all the things that we're talking
about here yeah
i mean i i was very um what that was
another really interesting thing about
going into america due to the kind of as
i mentioned the lack of public square
because when i was there it was really
hard to know
where it was going to go you know i i
had no idea
because you had no real feel of what
what people were thinking because there
wasn't
much going on at the time and i think
you know i had many of the worries on a
kind of personal perspective
that kind of many people described in
terms of the kind of rise of of
kind of institutional capture and the
kind of fusion of um
kind of the political institutions with
the already shifting culture of
of kind of wokeness in the kind of
cultural establishment and and that
being institutionalized in politics was
something that was really kind of
worrying to me
and i've also been you know quite i
think biden's hired a lot of
big tech kind of ceos and things like
that so that's a kind of very close
relationship but ultimately
you know i think i i wish him i wish him
luck and i wish that he uh
i hope that he heeds the calls that a
lot of people have said
um in terms of railing this in but i i'm
very worried about it i mean we've
already heard about
you know equity um and you know them
prioritizing
uh racial groups in the kind of
vaccination program
and so if it does continue down um that
line of you know
rabid identity politics then i think the
divisions that we've already seen
will only um continue and on top of that
you know biden
as much as he you know frames himself
and many people frame him
as a kind of new lovely old old man
face to the darkness we've experienced
and um
you know he he is very deep um into the
kind of um
the kind of uh institution the old kind
of political establishment of america
you know
we're talking you know he's been a
politician for about 50 years or more
and very much part of the
military-industrial complex and all of
that kind of foreign policy network
from decades ago and so you know i i i
worry that the divisions will continue
and i also think um i i understand a lot
of people's concerns about the kind of
extreme elements of of the trump
supporters
but i think um i don't think the
response
is this kind of ramping up of the kind
of domestic terrorism rhetoric
um which is in some senses feels um
like uh some of the very same problems
which led to
uh the kind of pre-2016 conditions which
led to the reaction
um in embodied in trump and so unless
people get serious about um really
trying to understand the reasons why so
many people
voted for perhaps a candidate that
doesn't fit the kind of traditional
um conception of a politician then i
think we could be in for a very
um a much more negative road and as
you know in britain as we mentioned
earlier you know we
we often experience the blowback of
american
kind of cultural hegemony and so it's in
our interest to
um encourage um real meaningful unity
not just unity and its rhetoric but
unity in the sense of taking a broad
range of american
citizens concerns genuinely seriously
and you use the words equality and
equity
i mean these are words that are banded
about i don't think a lot of people
would actually know the difference what
is the difference between equality and
equity
and why is one positive and one negative
so i think i think jordan peterson
particularly articulates it quite well
in the difference between a quality of
outcome and a quality of opportunity
so quality of opportunity is what we is
the kind of liberal idea of equality
where you um you don't differentiate you
know everybody
has the opportunity to for example go
into uh
for example a an elite university um
and and if they get the grades you know
regardless of your background then you
have an equal opportunity against
another person to get in and
and we strive towards achieving that
it's more of an ideal than obviously
in exact reality and the quality of
outcome which is
essentially equity which is that you
know you take for example the proportion
of
of the population by race and all um
institutions must
um fit exactly at the kind of elite
level the top level of those
institutions regardless of how many
people from that background apply
in some sense let's get some jews in the
premier league
like i'll be the one dude statistically
not playing for west ham
thank god oftentimes you know regardless
of if they even have the grades yeah
yeah um and again you know that is the
undoing
of the very heart hard fought for kind
of a quality of opportunity which was
seeing people
primarily as individuals not as members
of
competing identity categories and i
think that will only kind of ferment
the sense of resentment um that some
feel
that there's not fairness across the
board and so i i'm
strong but there's not the desire for
fairness that's why i think that's what
will
put a lot of people off it it's
deliberately discriminatory
by its very nature absolutely and i
think this is a similar thing you know
again
going back to kind of even free speech
how i think resentment
builds when there's double standards
right you know and i think when people
feel like you know it's not being
applied
equally then that's when that division
and polarization starts to increase
because i think
i think we all have an instinctive sense
of fairness
and not just the people that are victims
of the unfairness i think the people
that are exploiting
the way that it's unfair uh uh again
playing with things that
often have a very dark backlash and so
i'm a big believer in equality of
opportunity
i'm not not equity as such i mean coming
back to your previous point as well
about trump and biden and all of that i
think one thing people massively
underestimate and france neither francis
or our big trump fans by any stretch of
the imagination
got a lot of flack for saying so but
but the reality is that the only reason
in my view that biden won was
coronavirus
if you take that out of the equation
it's not like people suddenly won you
know what wokeness is great
right that didn't happen no exactly so
those resentments
not only are they still there as you say
quite likely to be exacerbated by some
of these policies
absolutely and i think um and you know
even just what we said about double
standards you know i i
you know the the what happened in
capitol hill as many people across the
political spectrum which has been quite
striking
has actually condemned it and we didn't
actually see that a lot of the violence
um
in in the kind of summer last year
wasn't always kind of universally
condemned
she's so diplomatic you put that so
gently it wasn't always you know he was
never condemned by anyone
yeah anyway sorry but
you know people aren't stupid you know
they see that
right and and you know we're not talking
about um
you know someone being rude on twitter
we're talking about real world
violence that led to people dying you
know that is horrendous
and and if people are not if there's not
a sense that there are
that as you said it is being applied
equally and and people are
and and it's only based off of political
lines your decision
to condemn then i i think you know i
think that that's a recipe for deep
deep deep division and so i think you
know the democrats have an opportunity
here and i'm not going to wish them
negatively
you know i want the country to do well
um but
um i i i worry that um you know that
there's a lot of hubris and um and or a
lot of ignoring
um the the the real uh reasons why we've
got to this point
as a society so i hope that they really
do heed those calls
but um you know as as everyone the
the it's been very unexpected all of the
changes that have happened in the last
couple years so we don't know we'll see
yeah
well a nice conciliatory message to end
the show on uh before we ask you our
last question just tell
everybody if the young person or indeed
if they're an older person
how they can get involved and support
the free speech champions project which
you're
launching yes go to
freespeechchampions.com if you're a
young person
applies to become a free speech champion
if you're anybody join join the free
speech network and we
want to work collaboratively you know
across the country and even beyond to
really
uh manifest a much more open and
free inquiry and and a promotion of free
speech so plea please check the website
freespeechchampions.com fantastic and we
always
uh end with the same question which is
what is the one thing we're not talking
about that we really should be
um that's a good question um i think one
thing we're not talking about
is i think this is the same one that i
actually said last time i was here but
we're still not talking about it
so it's fine i think the answer i think
the similar one that i said last time it
is agency i think the view of human
beings and whether that
you know is covered or even long time
before that as kind of weak and
vulnerable
and and um and you know unable to deal
with the realities of life
um is a very different view of the human
subject
to the heroic stories of before and i
think human beings are capable of much
more
and and great things and we should uh we
should champion that
i think that's a really important point
actually because i don't think it's
true to say that human beings aren't
weak and vulnerable in certain
circumstances but does it empower you to
think of yourself in that
way right and that is that is such an
important thing because your mindset
affects then your reality
absolutely you know it's a really good
point so we will start talking about it
now
you've mentioned it twice you know if i
never thank you so much for coming back
thank you for having me
and thank you for watching we will see
you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one
and they always go out 7pm uk time take
care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below